If you have followed
everything in the lesson so
far, then you are ready to understand
NP completeness, an idea behind
some of the most fascinating structure
in the P versus NP question.
You may have heard optimists say that
they are only one algorithm away
from proving that P is equal to NP.
What they mean is that if we could
solve just one NP complete problem
in polynomial time, then we could
solve all of them in polynomial time.
Here's why.
Formally, we say that a language
L is NP-complete if L is in NP,
and if every other language in NP can
be reduced to it in polynomial time.
Recalling our picture of P and
NP from the beginning of the lesson,
the NP complete problems were
the ones at the very top.
And we called them
the hardest problems in NP.
We can't have anything higher that's
still in NP, because if it's in NP,
then it can be reduced to
an NP complete problem.
Also, if any one of the NP complete
problems were shown to be in P
then P would extend up and
swallow all of NP.
It's not immediately obvious that
an NP complete problem even exists.
But it turns out that there are lots
of them and in fact they seem to
occur more often in practice than
the problems in this intermediate zone
which are not NP complete and so
far have not proved to be an NP either.
Historically, the first natural to
be proofed to be NP-complete is
boolean formula satisfiability,
or SAT for short.
This was shown to be NP-complete
by Stephen Cook in 1971 and
independently by Leonid Levin in
the Soviet Union around the same time.
The fact that this problem is
NP-complete is extremely powerful,
because once you have one NP-complete
problem, you just need to reduce it
to other problems to show that they,
too, are NP-complete.
Thus, much of the theory of complexity
can be said to rest on this theorem.
This is the high point of
our study of complexity.
So what exactly is this
satisfiability problem?